you want something like elaine maxwell
oh
okay bust it down for us mark all right
so basically deal with this trial
so basically glenn maxwell is not her
trial is now starting
uh actually i think it started today and
she's basically getting tried in
brooklyn where she's being held and
martha stewart yep same place as old
martha and basically she's being tried
for her connection to jeffrey epstein's
uh crimes against young children where
basically he was exploiting women and
like she was recruiting yeah and using
kids and she's not being charged with
that it doesn't seem like she's being
charged with just the recruitment and
the grooming of the young girls that
epstein was then exploiting in
quote-unquote trafficking got you now
i want to throw out a couple of
headlines and hopefully you can offer
some clarity
it has been said and a lot of news has
been made
out of the fact that this is not going
to be a public trial and that they're
not going to be streaming this anywhere
now there's certain trials that you can
watch in house written house we could
watch yeah oj
okay why can we not watch
get laid on the surface it looks like yo
they're protecting these [ __ ]
pedophiles they're finding a way yeah
why can we so there's two things one to
my understanding this is a federal case
and federal cases are not televised and
wisconsin allows you to televise a trial
in the state of wisconsin so written
house you can watch it and livestream
and that was a state and that was a
statement
federal you cannot gotcha yeah and then
the second piece is that there's a this
is sorry oj was also a statement
the state of california
[ __ ] love cameras in california yeah
and so my understanding also is that
there's at least what some of the media
companies are saying is that they don't
want to necessarily poison the jury by
putting out too much information about
the case at a federal level to then make
it so that the jurors are not able to be
selected i hope these [ __ ] are
poisoned
yeah yeah poison the jury what you're
basically saying is not literally kill
them which we have to say now
getting killed
um but like poison jury in terms of like
make them feel a certain way they have
to be going to this poison their
judgment against her exactly which we
should do
like come on the [ __ ] was [ __ ] the
kids yeah woman the kids
she was a rapist she's a rapist bro and
probably uh might be some bodies oh i'm
sure
allegedly now i don't know if she's
actually getting tried to say allegedly
she the first thing that happened was
like there's a bunch of like human
rights attorneys in like paris and new
york that are basically fighting on her
behalf saying that she has like unfair
and cruel conditions in prison yeah so
like she's having to sleep under
fluorescent light she's in solitary
confinement and they're saying that it's
cruel and unfair to do that to an
innocent person
so that was the first thing that came up
other people were like bro you're in
prison like this is not as bad as the
other prisons like there are prisoners
in jail right now that are not convicted
that are having a worse time than you
like so suck it up yeah yeah but then
they're pointing at like the american
prison system they're like how unfair is
this prison system blah blah blah and
they're wrapping it up in that she also
has i think pretty great attorneys
yeah they're acting like she's not gonna
beat the case yeah why don't we just see
where this money came from like follow
the money like if didn't she have these
big-ass accounts like 20 million 10
million dollars in them i think the last
thing i heard is her net worth is valued
right now like on books is like 22
million okay so where does the 22
million come from like you can figure
that out money has to get transferred to
your bank account from where let's just
follow that money and if that money
comes from a [ __ ] that was at
that island banging them kids
we need to ask you why he gave you 10
million why did prince andrew give you
five million dollars no that did happen
i think her defense based off what i
understand is that basically they're
going to say that she they're going to
basically blame everything on epstein
they're going to point to the empty
chair and be like yo this guy did
everything he she's actually a victim of
epstein
that
epstein mentally manipulated
he was like gaslighting her he like took
her from her family isolated her blah
blah blah didn't let her have contact
with the outside world the white woman
defense and then basically
that she was recruiting young girls and
she was talking to women to have him
work for
jeffrey epstein either as
masseurs which isn't illegal to
get a girl that's like hey do you want
to be a masseuse either as nannies which
isn't illegal to say hey do you want to
be a nanny and basically bringing women
in that she did not know was going to be
sexually exploited so she was kidnapped
as well yeah emotionally manipulated on
top of not knowing what she was actually
doing she was also a victim and also and
you know if she if she only had some
money to herself where she could leave
this operation and and you know not
continue working for him that would be
pretty easy but then maybe she's afraid
of being like killed et cetera
yeah i guess jeffrey epstein's a crazy
guy he's a maniac he's a psychopath and
he is the reason why she's in the
position and uh if she you're gonna let
her walk if you know if you think she
has dirt on everybody and like a [ __ ]
uh what do you call like a dead man
switch whatever they call it yeah then
you gotta let her walk that [ __ ] don't
exist you gotta walk that man switch
such [ __ ] everybody with dead man
switch nothing comes out right
everything got got an ain't no dead man
switch they got to the dead man switch
they switch that [ __ ] off how the dead
man switches you die it comes out that's
what they were figuring out while they
were torturing them in that cell ah bro
this is and then they're all going to
dispute what grooming is so they're
going to say you groom these young girls
you'll be like i talked to girls and
hired them that's grooming yeah i didn't
know what he was doing i was a mentor to
these women and now i'm grooming there
is an allegation that
in the epstein documentary i think on
netflix that one of the girls was saying
she and epstein raped me together yeah
so that's like a damage yeah that was
virginia dufrey who i don't think is
actually involved in this
current trial virginia gouffrey is the
one that was with prince andrew right
yeah yeah and i don't think she's one of
the four
uh defendants how the [ __ ] not not the
finish yeah yeah i don't understand
that's the big dog we're waiting for
another trial just try her for
everything at once
yeah i don't know how that works and
that's the other thing that they can end
up doing they could they could try her
for specific things that she can get off
um you know what i mean like
we don't even know if this is something
recent or this goes back to her time in
like what was it west palm
or just palm beach okay right so like
i think it's palm beach it's just so
this could be just palm beach right and
the accusations could be just palm beach
right and they could know that there's
no proof of what she actually did in
palm beach it could have nothing to do
with like luring [ __ ] into the
[ __ ] upper east side place that they
got right so we're looking at this going
oh yeah elaine was with him throughout
the entire time and they were in guilty
of like luring these women in and having
these sex parties and yadda yadda they
could be trying her for one year of [ __ ]
that happened in palm beach which is the
most easy to
um what is it beat which which could be
the most easy to beat right
they potentially could also be trying to
extradite her to england
where where she's from originally but
also like epstein had a house in london
where apparently some crimes occurred
also so they might be trying to create a
case against her to extradite her
so there's like all these different
things this isn't the internet when it
comes to like girl
yeah she's not getting this girl she's
walking
she's walking yo possible
name a girl like how do we not know one
girl who's gonna stand trial that's
crazy also we don't know one name i
think they're trying to stay
private
but we are they already put out the
video they were already talking in front
of the camera some of the i think only
one or two of them have like gone public
with their names the other two have like
chosen to stay anonymous
all i remember the girl with the crazy
teeth she crooked ass teeth do you
remember that girl she's talking about
escaping epstein's from the documentary
yes i don't know how many of those women
are the actual defendants
why not
yeah why not i don't understand why not
you don't go on netflix and say you got
raped and then when it's time to deliver
judgment to the rapist you're not there
also how are you going to [ __ ] [ __ ]
how are you going to find
jury members who are completely
unfamiliar with this case
everybody poisoned we all got netflix we
all had it during the pandemic we
watched everything yo i got a real
question for y'all
do you think
okay do you think the people that went
to the island knew that they were
underage
yes 100
90 i'm sure you found out somewhere
along the way
do you think that they
knew that they were underage as much as
someone who goes to like
[ __ ] dominican republic or colombia
for like bachelor parties
and
doesn't ask the age of the girls to show
up
interesting
i'm just saying like you hear all these
stories of like girls that like oh yeah
i started strip when i was 17. like
nobody at a strip club ever asked the
girl who's tripping how old they are now
i'm not trying to cap for the people who
went to the island what i am trying to
do is is understand intention
yeah you know what i mean so if like f i
don't think tiger woods went if malcolm
gladwell one of these [ __ ] goes
to the island is he going oh this is the
kid [ __ ] island i think if you've
been there more than once you've heard
also if you're going post 2008 when
epstein was convicted of awesome
yeah i think he was convicted of like
molestation or like
like crimes against children yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and like i said
that guy yeah 100 accused of crimes
against children
but prior to that
prior to that there's plausible
deniability i still think you probably
found out somewhere i'm just saying like
you never heard people saying they went
to [ __ ] brazil and like oh the strip
clubs are crazy it's like are you id
these [ __ ]
yeah no you're not yeah like you hear
these crazy stories but this is
different this is remember obama started
cutting we remember obama's like
security was in brazil and they got
caught going to the brothel or something
i don't remember the secret service
secret service they got caught going to
the brothel it's like you really think
the secret service is id in these
brazilian [ __ ] you just assume a part
of the institution like but this is
different the rules are different fam
it could be 16 there but this is you all
speak english you all talk you know
where you're from you from america let
me just get reactions you're from
america you know the rules 18 here do
you go by their rules over there if you
choose to
like i'm not saying it's ethical or not
ethical but like if you want to if
you're going to go to some other country
drink when it's 18 it's like oh it's
illegal to drink in america when it's
21. i'm just saying okay go
this is america is what i was going to
say if you're in brazil it's a whole
different culture a whole different
language i don't know how to communicate
with these people you're talking to
american girls on epson island for the
most part you can communicate with these
people if i'm having a conversation with
a child
it's a lot easier to find out if we're
having a conversation and this is a girl
that speaks english brazil you're just
like this is all different i don't know
what the [ __ ] this she's saying she
don't know what i'm saying i've never
been in this country the whole culture
is different i know there's strip clubs
everywhere i don't know if they're
vetting
it's easier to find out when it's an
american dude bringing you over to a
place it's easy to find out there's no
question about that
i just think that most people are
willfully ignorant when they go to these
places very willfully they go to brazil
they go to colombia they go to these
places where you know you're gonna go
and there's girls cuba dominican
republic where like there's just girls
around like i don't know if they're
asking for birthdays and that kind of
stuff like that
and i don't think that they're going
there to [ __ ] kids jesus so it looks
like the age of consent in colombia is
14 years boy
now based on your rules
i know you're not saying this but based
on what someone could interpret you're
saying well yeah that's what it's okay
over there
i mean i don't think you believe it it
violates my personal moral code but like
and i think if someone does that they're
a scumbag but also like if they're not
breaking laws what are you going to do
against them what i'm more talking about
is the dudes who do you know their
parties and [ __ ] they go over there and
they're not even asking questions that
could be 16 year old [ __ ] girls
they're just lined up and they out here
going epstein wasn't killed what is it
epstein piece of [ __ ] epstein this is
like fam you're doing the same thing
in spanish
i mean
at the very least i think guys in
general just ignorant regardless of age
when they go to another country for sex
tourism that they're complicit in like
sex trafficking yeah you just want to
[ __ ] some colombians yo yeah i'm in
colombia i want to [ __ ] some latinas i
think they know that you're flying to
[ __ ] palm beach to [ __ ] white girls
you know they're kids you know what i
mean but they're going to an island
where is this island full of white girls
that's not do you mean like
yeah
i don't know to me i don't i don't think
that white girls deserve to be [ __ ] no
not at all
not at all it's weird but i'm saying if
you're flying to if you're going to
[ __ ] houses in columbia brazil it's
like yo i'm just trying to [ __ ] some
latin you already know you're doing
something illegal if you're flying to an
island to [ __ ] a bunch of american girls
take race out of it just american girls
who speak english i'm probably on an
island for a weird [ __ ] reason yeah
there's [ __ ] houses around me
everywhere and i'm a powerful guy i
could access some high-class [ __ ]
yeah high-class horse
so why am i going to this island with
american girls
i'm saying i don't think they really
have plausible deniability
got you i got you i'm with you on that i
i'm just saying like
there's there's this huge outrage
about the island and the girls and it's
disgusting we should be outraged
but we all know [ __ ] that go to
places for sex tourism
and we all know [ __ ] who are
not asking ideas at these places right
those people are disgusted by epstein
yeah
they are repulsed by him thinks think
that he is a [ __ ] monster
while they are filling the pockets
of the hispanic version of epstein in
these places fair enough all right
that's
that's the thing that i find a little
peculiar like
he's not the only one that got [ __ ]
teenagers banging adults
right so you're not as much trying to ex
exonerate the people who went to fc
island clinton what a disgusting piece
of [ __ ] for [ __ ] teenagers on an
island
oh when is your bachelor party oh where
are we going dominican republic yeah all
right bet
yeah
yeah
yes disgusting for [ __ ] those young
girls
but there are people out here that
should not be
that should not be calling him out for
it put it that way right
i think there's also a difference like
being complicit in the sex trafficking
and like
doing the sex trafficking
like i think those people should use
different jail centers yeah he's saying
i think
don't
judge other people judging bill clinton
who are you judging all these
[ __ ] on the plane yeah i
thought you were more exonerating the
guys who went to epstein island as
opposed to accusing these guys of being
hypocrites
for me it's always the hypocrisy yeah
and if that wasn't clear my bad but it's
just like
you know you bet you know you
specifically went to places
because it was easy to [ __ ] these
[ __ ] yeah
and who are you you know you're not
asking the [ __ ] price yeah they also
ask themselves probably like they
justify their own thing based off their
own intention like this is like you know
where they're like oh i'm going to south
america to have sex with women
and i don't care really what their ages
are i'm not going to ideal but i'm going
to have sex with women whereas these
people are going to the island to abuse
kids that's true but you are to the
point is that i've that stuck with me is
you are still lining the pockets of
their epstein's yeah and they're also
abusing kids like if you go to like
south america or whatever it's like in
your head they're women but they're kids
potentially and i bet you they're summer
kids and some are adults and i bet you
there's probably [ __ ] that went
to epson [ __ ] like hey i'm going to this
island to [ __ ] women because here's the
thing
a lot of people got to understand
there are parties around the world
where women are just brought there to
[ __ ] the guys at the party
that's not a
that's not like an abstract concept here
like there are parties
where it's a few guys that are there and
then there are women that are just
funneled into the party and their job
yeah is to [ __ ] whoever's there right
that's your job
they're paid for
these girls could be russian they could
be brazilian they could be american they
could be cuban they could be whatever
the [ __ ] they are but they're women that
do not have opportunities in life and
they're there to [ __ ] the rich guys that
are at the party yeah
to look at this as
this only happens on epson island it
should be willfully ignorant to what
goes on every single weekend around the
world right like every weekend that's
true like
you go out and party in new york they're
legal
you go out and party in new york you go
to one of these nightclubs they're women
they're just paid to hang out by the
bottles they get money they're paid
they're not supposed to [ __ ] the people
but please believe sometimes they get
[ __ ]
now it's their choice
but i would imagine that the girls who
give up some [ __ ] more often
get paid more often to be at the party
right they're more fun
they get flown around yeah like sex
tourism exists yeah we're completely
okay with it
and we're focusing just on this like one
specific instance because it's got all
these powerful people involved and it's
what i'm saying is the age thing exists
everywhere everywhere okay
yeah yeah like you go to you go it's
disgusting parts of like southeast asia
and [ __ ] like that's the whole game
you're not going there for how old the
women look yeah like the people that go
to like where like and they age the best
like if there's one place you can [ __ ]
an old woman and you're going to look
young it's asia and they still want the
i think it just gets closer to home
because it's it's happening in our
country also like if it's happening
these guys are pieces of [ __ ] if they're
doing it in southeast asia they're
[ __ ] gross they're monsters at these
parties but it's gonna hit closer to
home if it's happening in [ __ ]
florida
or an island there's girls from florida
like
you know clinton's obviously yeah
absolutely yeah so many different things
perfect it confirms people's idea also
like rich people you're like information
this like all of people that are all
connected through this pedophilic
sacrifice whatever else
rich people are bad politicians are bad
all these rich elites they're doing
[ __ ] up things yeah i don't have that
stuff because i'm not willing to do
those [ __ ] up things yeah the only way
you can get there is if you do [ __ ] up
things what the perfect story to
convince me that i'm 100 right that's
awesome now i can forget about it go get
married where am i going to do my
bachelor party [ __ ]
saigon seems like a good place
yeah
no i'm just i don't know maybe there is
hypocrisy is there something yeah again
i again i thought you were more trying
to explain the way that people went to
epson's fc island and no i think they
knew
but the hypocrisy i see
i guess yeah i guess what i'm trying to
say is like whether they knew they
didn't know
their willful ignorance is a problem
yeah
that's fantastic yeah i think that's a
problem like if you know it could
yeah you got to be vigilant you know
like yeah and honestly it's probably
worse if you're a powerful person
because you got a lot of [ __ ] to lose so
like you should be more vigilant about
this kind of thing i'm curious what the
pretext is also like i wonder if epstein
because he's trying to blackmail people
allegedly that's the way i understand
like he's trying to get dirt on people
so if he's bringing people down being
like oh yeah like i have some friends
that are also coming to hang out like
they they're all cool like talk to him
if you want and then the girls are like
super extra like they're not paying for
it they're just like wow like you know
jeff's friend is like super nice to me i
guess she's into me that's so cool so it
depends on if he's trying to trap these
people which then absolves some of the
people potentially of their intent
whereas some people are going like yo
i'm going with jeffrey epstein i'm about
to bang a bunch of kids those people
obviously fit into me like a different
box yeah i mean think about it if it's a
trap
the last thing you want to do is
incriminate somebody until afterwards
yeah it's like if i'm trying to poison
you i don't go hey here's some poison in
your food enjoy it yeah you do the exact
opposite this is the best food ever
whatever yeah delicious so you just say
yo these are my friends they just came
in or they're in town and they're gonna
come part with us is that cool like i
know you're married but like they're
gonna come hang is that fine yeah so i'm
assuming if epstein's trying to get
these people which to me it seems like
he is most people seem to believe that
as well yeah so are all the people that
ever went to the island that had sex
with women there are they all guilty of
the same thing i'm like
they all did the same [ __ ] up thing
but if epstein's trying to trap him
that's different than if they're going
there on their own volition trying to
just try
yeah and now you got one of these
[ __ ] that you know really likes
it and you get your hooks in yeah that
prince andrew was like hey i really
enjoyed that specific type of party yeah
yeah you're gonna have more of those and
you're like oh he's mine yeah you keep
feeding the beast feeding the beast and
now you got him and you can do whatever
the [ __ ] you want with him yeah yeah
that could be the game it could be the
low key the game could have been just
bait
mm-hmm like
he could have had above-aged girls there
too i'll bring everyone in and then the
people that happen to filter into this
creepy [ __ ] pedophilic [ __ ] then he's
like oh yeah they're mine yeah hopefully
he's a rich guy hopefully he's connected
to the royals and i'm only inviting rich
connected people yeah so one of those
dudes drinks a little bit gets a little
loose and starts talking to a teeny
bopper
hooks in
hmm
[Music]
yeah i mean people that are complicit in
sex tourism in general i don't think
they are completely self-actualized yeah
what do you mean by that like they're
going into some third world country
going like i'm gonna be involved in
prostitution at the very least oh
self-actualizing yeah like
self-awareness they're going away to do
a legal [ __ ] and they're not really
thinking about too much because it makes
them feel weird no one goes and bangs a
bunch of prostitutes that have dubious
agents comes back like yes yeah i did it
i had a great time
you have to cope with it actually to be
honest
mark
they do bro it's
bro it's crazy oh man we're down there
we're taking down four four each
something like that five of us like it's
crazy that the stories they they're
paying for it but they're still like
yeah i mean i had that joke about the
strip clubs like any time guys would
brag about strip clubs i'm like
you paid them like i don't understand
why you're bragging about paying for
[ __ ] yeah i mean that's how i feel
anytime someone comes back from a trip
and they're like bragging i'm like all
right yeah
and the buddies
in the back of my mind i'm like you
spent a lot of money and didn't get any
[ __ ] yeah strip club wise
you